[Musique]
bonjour et merci de nous rejoindre pour
un nouveau numéro du 7-8 loisirs chaque
jeudi l'essentiel des informations pour
passer un bon week-end dans les yvelines
et tout de suite le sommaire la tête
dans les étoiles ou chimiste en herbe du
5 au 19 octobre c'est la fête de la
science à 50 ans les bulles le point sur
la programmation découvrir le golf de
manière ludique ce week-end golf
expérience revient pour une septième
édition qui se poursuivra en nocturne et
l'agenda complet de vos sorties au
programme de la culture du cinéma et des
plaisirs gourmands plusieurs formes
plusieurs lieux ce samedi à 5 octobre 50
en huile invite à faire une nuit blanche
de 20h à minuit vous pourrez assister à
des spectacles découvrir des oeuvres
numériques interactives ou encore des
projections d'oeuvres un circuit a même
été mis en place pour visiter tous les
lieux dans la même soirée
je vous propose de regarder un extrait
d'un des moments de la soirée la
compagnie retouramont présente ses jeux
d'échelle
[Musique]
comme chaque semaine on retrouve notre
instance cinéma aujourd'hui direction
saint cyr l'école pour rencontrer
bertrand vignes et des rendez vous pour
les petits comme les plus grands
[Musique]
au cinéma les yeux d'elsa ce mois ci
c'est le mois du cinéma d'animation
comme tous les ans au mois d'octobre on
fait des focus sur le cinéma d'animation
et cette année on a décidé de faire un
focus sur le cinéma d'animation japonais
comme on le fait très souvent ou parce
qu'en plus il ya des films extrêmement
importants qui sont sortis les six
derniers mois et on n'avait pas eu
l'occasion de les passer donc vous allez
pouvoir éventuellement les revoir
éventuellement les rattraper on va vous
diffuser pendant une toute une partie du
mois d'octobre les films le mystère des
pingouins wonderland le royaume sans
pluie et les enfants de la mer avec en
particulier le samedi 19 octobre une
soirée après midi soirée animation
qui commence à ses heures et qui finira
à 23h avec les trois films que je viens
de citer
chaque film à 3,060 si on organise cette
soirée c'est aussi parce que sans cire
comme l'année dernière organise un
concours de dessin manga et que le
samedi 19 octobre
on vous en dira plus dans la salle du
cinéma les yeux d'elsa
alors rendez vous nombreux pour
découvrir ces trois films l'un les deux
l'autre comme vous voulez en tout cas le
19 octobre vous pourrez découvrir ces
films qui ont qui ont été des très
grands succès et qui sont pour certains
issus de deux mangas extrêmement connue
à très bientôt au cinéma les idées
bizarres apprentis chimistes passionné
par l'espace où avide d'aventurés notre
premier rendez vous et pour vous du 5 au
19 octobre la science prend place à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines flora tout et
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes la
responsable de l'atelier des sciences le
thème de cette année c'est les mesures
qu'est ce que c'est alors donc c'est le
thème régional de la fête de la science
donc pour rappel la fête de la science
est organisée chaque année par le
ministère de la recherche d'innovation
et de l'enseignement supérieur c'est la
28e édition le but de la fête de la
science c'est de vulgariser les sciences
de rendre accessibles les sciences de
créer une rencontre entre les
scientifiques et le public est chaque
année un thème régional et choisit donc
cette année ce sont les mesures donc les
mesures en science qu'est ce que ça
signifie
finalement ma des mesures on les utilise
tout le temps donc le but est de voir
comment les scientifiques utilisent les
mesures dans leur quotidien voilà le fil
pour mesurer les ondes on peut mesurer
plein de choses en fait
tout à fait et donc ça on en parlera
après au village des sciences mais vous
pourrez découvrir beaucoup de façons de
traiter cette thématique
voilà alors il ya quelques rendez-vous
qui vont s'afficher à l'écran bien sûr
on peut pas tout référencer toutes
annoncées mais surtout ce qu'on voit
s'il ya une grande diversité
d'animations il ya des ateliers des
contes d expérience tout à fait donc du
simple au 19 octobre vous pouvez
retrouver dans
les médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des ateliers
donc les médiathèques ont choisi non pas
les mesures mais l'astronomie donc des
ateliers autour du système solaire des
cadrans solaires au tour voilà du soleil
et donc ce sont des ateliers ludiques
avec des expériences des manipulations
essentiellement pour les enfants il y a
aussi des conférences et puis les
adultes cette fois tout à fait pour les
adultes donc notamment avec des
chercheurs du latmos ce qui est un
laboratoire du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
et puis des comptes également pour les
tout petits à partir de 4 ans c'est ça
l'idée vous avez nommés les médiathèques
vous avez mentionné le latmos est l'un
des deux laboratoires du territoire que
sur halo vs q vous avez mobiliser tous
les acteurs qui ont une petite place
dans cet univers de la science tout à
fait donc à la fois des professionnels
c'est-à-dire des chercheurs des
ingénieurs des techniciens et puis aussi
des associations de culture scientifique
dont l'objet est vraiment de rendre
accessibles à toutes les thématiques
scientifiques de façon ludique ludique
pourquoi pour rendre la science plus
intéressantes on a peut-être une petite
barrière entre les recherches actuelles
et les enfants du public que premier
cible est alors intéressant que je ne
sais pas mais les pour présenter la
science d'une autre façon alors il y a
un temps fort vous l'avez mentionné très
rapidement tout à l'heure c'est du 11
octobre aux traits du 11 au 13 octobre
c'est le village des sciences
alors le bon c'est pour le les scolaires
mais le week-end c'est pour le public
qu'est ce qui va se passer
cela fait donc chaque année on organise
un village les des sciences qui
rassemble une trentaine de partenaires
scientifiques donc aussi bien des
entreprises par exemple ils eurent à
airbus ou thalès représenté par le
réseau ingénieurs pour l'école il y aura
des laboratoires on classe le latmos à
nouveau l'inra aussi des enseignants
chimie de l'ue vs cul et puis des
associations en astronomie géologie des
associations de culture scientifique des
partenaires du territoire des de
l'agglomération
vous pourrez faire donc vous balader
passé l'après midi à la commanderie et
faire des expériences des manipulations
tout l'après midi vous pourrez c'est
gratuit j'imagine tout à fait vous
pouvez aussi participer à un atelier
proposé par le latmos qui est un petit
peu plus long et puis assister à une
séance de planétarium
il y aura aussi des contes et des
conférences et tout ça c'est à retrouver
sur le site qui va s'afficher en battre
les grands de l'écran qui est ce que
pose qui point fr merci flora tout et on
le rappelle la fête de la science début
de ce samedi 5 octobre sur saint quentin
en yvelines pour ne rien rater des
rendez-vous direction le site quelques
autres rendez vous pour les gourmands
cette fois c'est la fête du miel à
plaisir ce week-end les abeilles vous
régale pendant deux jours dans la cour
des communs du château
au programme extraction de miel
dégustation et échanges avec des
apiculteurs à versailles c'est les
créateurs qui sont à l'honneur la
révolution du fait-main organise la
troisième édition du marché des
créations fait main et médine france des
ateliers complètent la programmation et
pour en découvrir un peu plus les
organisatrices de l'événement étaient
les invités de grégory canal et du
journal de ce jeudi 3 octobre
et c'est un retrouver sur notre site
internet tv 78 points com quel est votre
paysages préférés de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'agglomération vous propose d'y
répondre en trois photographies trois
thématiques vous attendent de nombreux
lots de nombreux lots sont à gagner
toutes les informations sont disponibles
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran
[Musique]
à quelques jours de l'open de france qui
réunira quelques-uns des meilleurs
golfeurs saint quentin en yvelines vous
propose de vous essayer au golf c'est le
retour de la golf expérience pour cette
septième édition de golf blue green de
l'île de loisirs accueille les curieux
et passionnés ce samedi 5 octobre de 14h
à minuit autour d'activités multiples
disc-golf ateliers d'initiation et un
parc ou non nocturne je ne prends que la
ryder cup a fait connaître largement le
golfe mais aujourd'hui il faut montrer
que c'est le golf est accessible à tout
le monde et c'est le but en fait de
cette manifestation c'est de faire
découvrir le golf de façon ludique et
pour tous de façon gratuite pour les
amateurs de randonnée la rando challenge
vous attend à magny les hameaux un
rallye pédestre organisé par le comité
78 de la fédération française de
randonnée de niveau sont proposés entre
15 et 18 km en mode compétition ou en
découvertes sur un circuit de 8 à 12 km
le parcours à réaliser en équipe se fait
sur un itinéraire donné mais pas
seulement écouter le président du comité
ont ils vont trouver son parcours des
questions qui sont relatives soit de
documentation que deux reçu à de
l'observation le patrimoine ma nature ça
permet surtout aux équipes de découvrir
le lieu où circulent l'accueil des
participants débuts dès 8 heures 30 au
gymnase auguste delaune de magny les
hameaux
on sort maintenant du département pour
découvrir une activité inédite
[Musique]
cette semaine nos confrères de via grand
paris vous entraîne dans la capitale
avec un jeu d'adressé le lancer de hache
une sortie insolite à pratiquer dans le
18e arrondissement regarder pour se
défouler voici le lancer h à la
canadienne une activité insolite niché
dans le 18e arrondissement chez les
cogner ici on apprend à manier l'outil
du bûcheron c'est pas la peine de tirer
comme des brutes dès le départ c'est le
geste qui va faire que là je vais
planter comme il faut et ensuite il faut
bien pris votre chef vous pourrez
accompagner avec un peu plus de vent les
adeptes vielle surtout ici pour s'amuser
entre amis en couple ou encore entre
collègues on a un peu de tout après ça
peut aller du dating heures donc des
jeunes jusqu'à jeu quand même des
entreprises
on vient ici on vient se défouler et
puis c'est bon on a vu et on à évacuer
toute la frustration de la journée le
boss qui nous quitte sur elle c'est bon
tout est parti si jamais il ya besoin
même on peut même accroché des photos
sur les cibles puis là on se défoule
jusqu'au bout là c'est bon ça reste du
lancer de hache même si le risque est
très moindre étant nommé que les âges
sont émoussés et où et quand même la
sécurité à prendre en compte et donc
c'est quand même une activité où des
restrictions sont surtout présentes en
toute prudence
ils s'entraînent pendant 15 minutes le
but réussir à planter là h au centre de
la cible et acquérir la technique pour
gagner le tournoi à venir dans trois
jeux différents il lancé après il faut
les attaquer nombre de points précis et
à la fin on a le temps appelle le killer
c'est les mêmes règles comme holt yuko
fléchettes par exemple il y en a souvent
qui à mon sens la référence c'est en
fait le premier avait un point pile dès
qu'on dépasse les 20 points du court où
les points se retranche il ya moyen de
légaliser les autres les faire retomber
à zéro c'est un jeu qui dure assez
longtemps que c'est sympa et qui qui
crée un peu d'émulation c'est en général
c'est assez marrant
la séance se termine par une photo
souvenir deux croix
de quoi faire de vous un véritable bûche
compte et qui s'est intégré la
fédération française de lancer h
c'est la fin du set 8 loisirs vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile on se retrouve jeudi
prochain à 18h30 pour de nouvelles cités
sortis
[Musique]
m